El presidente de Colombia, Gustavo Petro llegó
al gobierno en 2022 con grandes promesas de
cambio en prácticamente todos los sectores
políticos, sociales y económicos del país.
Digamos que el nuevo presidente se propuso
cambiar Colombia de arriba abajo.
Uno de estos grandes cambios es, precisamente,
su plan transición energética, el cual pasa
por mucho que os pueda sorprender, por un
abrupto cese de cualquier nuevo contrato de
exploración y explotación petrolera en el
territorio colombiano.
Es decir, que Colombia puede convertirse en
una de las principales potencias petroleras
en vetar esta industria.
Y, ojo, que hablamos de unos de los sectores
económicos más importantes, qué más dinero
aportan a las arcas públicas y el número
uno en término de exportaciones.
La pregunta es, ¿Qué puede suponer para
Colombia romper con la industria petrolera?
¿Por qué lo hacen?
¿Qué van a sacrificar?
¿Tiene sentido una medida como esta?
Pues bien, este vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas.
Arranquemos.
Con unas reservas probadas de cerca de 2.000
millones de barriles, Colombia se encuentra
entre los 35 países con mayores reservas
de oro negro del mundo.
En concreto, en este país existen 23 zonas
geológicas, con diferentes cuencas, de las
cuales solo nueve producen hidrocarburos:
siete producen petróleo, y dos, producen
gas.
(De las siete cuencas productoras de crudo,
solo tres concentran más del 90 % de la producción.
Estas son las cuencas de los Llanos Orientales,
del Valle Medio y Valle Superior del Magdalena.
En total, de los 20 departamentos que extraen
petróleo actualmente, solo uno extrae petróleo
ligero, mientras que el resto producen crudo
mediano o pesado.)
Estos serían grosso modo los detalles.
Como veis, el perfil petrolero colombiano
no es precisamente el de un país como Arabia
Saudí, pero sí que tiene potencial.
Aunque, eso sí, vaya lo que les costó aprovecharlo.
Atentos porque aquí comienza toda esta historia.
(T1.
LOS PRIMEROS PASOS: LA ALERGIA A LA RENTABILIDAD)
El primer pozo de petróleo de la historia
de Colombia se perforó ya en el año 1918,
en el campo Cira-Infantas, donde a penas se
llegaban a producir 2000 barriles diarios.​
Tres años después, se construyó la primera
refinería del país, en Barrancabermeja,
y también el primer oleoducto, en Mamonal,
cercano a Cartagena.
Y de esta forma es como hace ya algo más
de 100 años se puso en marcha la industria
petrolera colombiana.
Sin embargo, durante mucho tiempo no se obtuvo
ningún provecho de esta industria.
En 1951, buscando darle un giro de tuerca
a este asunto, el por aquel entonces gobierno
de Laureano Gómez nacionalizó y le otorgó
varias concesiones petroleras a la recién
formada Empresa Colombiana de Petróleos,
Ecopetrol, una empresa pública creada para
que el Estado colombiano pudiese participar
activamente e impulsar esta industria.
De esta forma, aunque durante esos años gigantes
como Texaco o la Shell comenzaron a interesarse
por el petróleo colombiano, las condiciones
de exploración y extracción eran totalmente
desventajosas para ellos.
La presencia de Ecopetrol era el principal
escolló.
El gobierno solo tenía ojos para ella, y
esta entidad no solo era una empresa que competía
en la exploración y producción, sino que
actuaba también como el organismo público
que regulaba este sector.
Así que de una forma u otra, todas las empresas
privadas estaban obligadas a asociarse con
su virtual competidor en condiciones poco
atractivas.
Y así, durante casi todo el siglo XX se probaron
distintos regímenes jurídicos, que a decir
verdad, parecían ir de mal en peor.
(Por ejemplo, entre 1974 y 1989, operó un
régimen llamado “Contrato 50/50”, que
tenía la misión de impulsar la inversión.
Pese a ello, bajo este marco el socio privado
asumía el coste y el riesgo de la inversión
en exploración, que tenía que completarse
en un plazo máximo de tres años.
Eso sí, cuando comenzaba la producción el
reparto del beneficio que quedaba se hacía
de la siguiente forma:
Un 20% para el estado en concepto de regalías,
un 40% para Ecopetrol y un 40% para el inversor
privado.
Por supuesto, luego el inversor privado tenía
que pagar los correspondientes impuestos sobre
beneficios.
¿El resultado?
Entre el 85% y el 90% de los beneficios de
la explotación iban a parar al estado.
El inversor privado apenas recibía el resto,
lo que, lógicamente, resultaba muy poco atractivo.)
En 1987 se trató de mejorar esta norma, aunque
bueno tratar, es mucho decir: lo único que
se hizo fue que ECOPETROL tuviera una participación
más alta en el costo de la exploración.
Pero no cambiaba a grandes rasgos el modelo.
Por eso en 1989 se puso en marcha un nuevo
régimen, que estaría vigente hasta 1994.
Ce creó la figura conocida como “Contrato
de Distribución de la Producción”.
En este esquema el socio privado asumía el
costo y riesgo exploratorio, hasta que se
efectuaba el descubrimiento.
En ese momento Ecopetrol entraba a participar
de la siguiente manera:
Ya lo veis, cuanto más rentable era el pozo
descubierto, menos participación le quedaba
al inversor.
Si este modelo atrajo un aluvión de inversiones
lo debió de hacer lejos del petróleo colombiano.
Porque, de hecho, un yacimiento con apenas
60 millones de barriles ya era de por sí
escasamente rentable.
Por supuesto, este modelo no funcionó, así
que en 1995 se lanzó una nueva fórmula,
denominada “FACTOR R”.
En este caso la distribución de la producción
se hacía basándose en la rentabilidad del
campo petrolero sin tener en cuenta la magnitud
de las reservas.
Sin embargo, no era nada fácil calcular los
ingresos y los beneficios esperados, lo que
producía mucha incertidumbre.
Una incertidumbre que, por supuesto, espantaba
a los inversores.
Así que ahora seguro que ya entendéis por
qué durante prácticamente todo el siglo
XX la riqueza petrolera de Colombia apenas
se explotó.
Y eso que el mayor interesado de que creciera
la producción era el propio estado, que era
quien se llevaba la mayor parte de los beneficios
en conceptos de impuestos y regalías.
Así que seguro, seguro que muchos tenéis
la solución en la cabeza, parece bastante
obvia.
Sin embargo, tardo mucho en llegar.
Atentos.
(T2.
EL DESPEGUE)
No todo estaba perdido.
Durante la presidencia de Andrés Pastrana,
ECOPETROL dio un giro muy importante.
Durante la conocida como convocatoria de la
Ronda 2000, el estado hizo una serie de concursos
para explorar y producir en proyectos en los
que la empresa estatal solo tendría el 30%
de la participación.
Por supuesto, eso llamó la atención de las
grandes petroleras del mundo.
.
Para que os hagáis una idea, esa iniciativa
culminó con la adjudicación de 13 proyectos,
con más de 600 millones de dólares de inversión
inicial.
Sin embargo, el gran cambio para el sector
petrolero colombiano aún estaba por llegar:
En el año 2003, el por aquel entonces presidente
Alvaro Uribe Velez, ordenó la reestructuración
del sector, yendo directo a la raíz del problema.
El entonces gobierno colombiano creo la Agencia
Nacional de Hidrocarburos, de tal forma que
Ecopetrol perdió sus facultades regulatorias.
De esta forma, la empresa pública pasaría
a estar enfocada por completo a la exploración,
la producción, el transportarte, la refinación
y la comercialización de los hidrocarburos.
Es decir, se convertía así en una petrolera
al uso.
Al mimo tiempo el gobierno puso en marcha
un nuevo contrato de regalías, impuestos
y derechos.
El nuevo modelo imitaba los estándares internacionales
y limitaba la participación total del Estado
a un rango de entre el 50 y 60% de los beneficios
cosechados.
¿Y sabéis qué ocurrió?
Que a partir de ese momento la producción
se disparó, y con ella también las exportaciones.
De repente, el sector petrolero colombiano
cobro vida.
Fijaos.
De esta forma, mientras la producción venezolana
hacía aguas, Colombia cobraba cada vez más
peso en el sector petrolero de América Latina.
Los niveles de producción alcanzados hubieran
sido completamente inimitables apenas unos
cuantos años antes.
Claro que también había problemas.
La caída de los precios del petróleo en
el año 2015 redujo la inversión en este
sector en cerca de un 30% y la perforación
de nuevos pozos en más del 80%.
Entonces el gobierno de Juan Manuel Santos
tuvo que plantear una reforma tributaria para
contener la caída de los ingresos fiscales
que generaba el petróleo.
Digamos que el tesoro colombiano se había
vuelto muy dependiente de los nuevos ingresos
públicos que había traído consigo el oro
negro.
Pero, no nos desviemos.
Sea como sea, pese a todo el sector se consolidó
y las exportaciones de hidrocarburos continuaron
ganando peso entre las exportaciones colombianas.
Hoy esta industria es responsable de algo
más de un tercio de todas las exportaciones
de Colombia.
En cierto modo hablamos de una especie de
milagro petrolero que contribuyó a cambiar
el país.
En apenas una década, entre los años 2003
y 2013, el país pasó de tener casi que importar
crudo a convertirse, por ejemplo, en un importante
proveedor de Estados Unidos.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Justo ahora, la falta de inversión que durante
años se ha producido en la industria petrolera
internacional y la invasión rusa de Ucrania
han puesto sobre la mesa la posibilidad que
Colombia experimente una nueva era dorada
de los hidrocarburos.
Sin embargo, el nuevo presidente ha dicho
que nanay.
Qué la explotación del petróleo ya no tiene
cabida en Colombia.
Atentos.
(T3.
PETRO SÍ, “LEO” NO)
A finales de 2021, en plena campaña electoral
por la presidencia de Colombia, el futuro
de la industria petrolera era un tema relevante
en la agenda económica de los candidatos.
La posición más contundente era la de Gustavo
Petro, que prometía nada más y nada menos
que el cese de las concesiones petroleras.
Fijaos.
(Una, cesa la contratación de exploración
de petróleo en Colombia.
Mensaje: vamos hacía una economía productiva,
no extractivista.
Habrá una transición tranquila, pero segura
y sería que empezará el primer día de gobierno.
Gustavo Petro)
Pues bien, finalmente este candidato se convirtió
el 19 de junio del 2022 en el presidente electo
de la República de Colombia.
Y en noviembre de ese mismo 2022, tan solo
un año después de su promesa, se lanzó
a un discurso aún más arriesgado en la Conferencia
de la ONU sobre Cambio Climático.
Fijaos.
(La crisis climática solo se supera si dejamos
de consumir hidrocarburos.
Es hora de desvalorizar la economía de los
hidrocarburos con fechas definidas para su
final.
[...] La solución es un mundo sin petróleo
y sin carbón.)
Pero, esperad, porque el verdadero bombazo
llegó el 19 de enero de 2023, cuando Irene
Vélez, ministra de Minas y Energía, confirmó
que Bogotá ya no firmará nuevos contratos
de exploración petrolera:
(Decidimos también que no vamos a conceder
nuevos contratos de exploración de gas y
petróleo.
Eso ha sido por supuesto muy polémico a nivel
nacional.
Irene Vélez)
Por supuesto, esto ha generado mucho temor,
no solo en el sector petrolero, sino en toda
la industria y prácticamente en toda la economía
colombiana: ¿perderá este país una de sus
fuentes de dólares e ingresos públicos más
importantes?
¿Está en riesgo la seguridad del abastecimiento?
Y es que, veréis, actualmente Colombia mantiene
330 contratos de exploración y explotación,
los cuales seguirán produciendo hidrocarburos
tanto para el mercado interno como para la
exportación durante aproximadamente diez
años.
La pregunta es, ¿y después de eso, qué?
Pues esto es lo que dice el presidente Petro:
C1(“Según las proyecciones de la Agencia
Internacional de Energía, nos quedan cinco
años de exportación de carbón y 10 de petróleo
(...) La transición tiene que ver con dos
aspectos.
Uno, lograr que las divisas que dejamos de
obtener por exportar carbón y petróleo sean
reemplazadas en la misma magnitud por exportaciones
de energías limpias y turismo principalmente.
Dos, (conseguir que) nuestro propio consumo
interno de carbón y petróleo se reemplace
electrificando el transporte, cambiando nuestra
matriz energética y descarbonizando la producción.”
Gustavo Petro, 21 de enero de 2023)
C2(“Habrá transición estrictamente energética,
pero manteniendo la exportación de petróleo,
en niveles que nos permitan disponer de las
divisas que el país necesita (...) Yo diría
que la petrolera durará unos 15 años”.
José Antonio Ocampo, ministro de Hacienda
de Colombia)
Es decir, que parece que más o menos tiene
un plan: forzar la transición energética.
La pregunta es, ¿se logrará en 10 años?
¿Merece la pena perder miles de millones
de dólares de ingresos potenciales en un
país que sigue siendo muy pobre y que tiene
tantas carencias, por ejemplo, en infraestructuras?
Al fin y al cabo, los datos son muy claros.
Son contundentes.
C3(“La industria de hidrocarburos es fundamental
para la estabilidad económica del país,
la financiación nacional y la de los departamentos
y municipios.
Cerca del 40% de las exportaciones dependen
de este sector, el 20% de los ingresos fiscales
de la Nación y el 76% de las regalías.
Diversificar la canasta exportadora debe ser
un objetivo, pero no a costa de marchitar
la industria.”
Comunicado de la Asociación Colombiana de
Petróleo y Gas, 20 enero de 2023.)
Queridos amigos, amigas, la polémica y el
miedo a perder miles de millones de dólares
en inversión extranjera y en ingresos públicos
fue tal, que el propio Petro parece haber
dado marcha atrás.
Al menos, parcialmente.
Sí, sigue teniendo en la diana a la industria
de los hidrocarburos y posiblemente la concesión
de nuevas licencias de exploración y producción
se desplome, pero al menos en el plan de transición
energética presentado se contemplan nuevas
concesiones.
Sea como sea, el futuro de esta industria
en Colombia no parece particularmente halagüeño.
Y la pregunta es, ¿es suficiente el paso
atrás dado por el presidente Petro?
¿Qué impacto podría tener para Colombia
que este presidente cumpliera sus planes?
Pues…
Atentos.
(T4.
¿DEL MILAGRO A LA DEBACLE PETROLERA?)
Queridos amigos, las palabras siempre cuentan,
pero las declaraciones de un presidente lo
suelen hacer mucho más.
Con su discurso, Petro ha calcinado la confianza
de un sector que iba viento en popa y a toda
vela.
De hecho, en 2022 la inversión en exploración
alcanzó su mejor registro desde el año 2014.
Ahora se espera que en 2023 la tendencia se
dé la vuelta y la inversión vuelva a caer.
Y eso que hablamos de concesiones ya formalizadas.
Y por supuesto, si los planes de Petro se
consolidan, entonces los problemas podrían
ir mucho más allá de las petroleras, la
entrada de divisas en el país o, incluso,
los propios ingresos del gobierno.
Hablamos de miles y miles de empleos, hablamos
de que el precio de los combustibles podría
encarecerse, lo que perjudicaría al ingreso
de millones de familias.
Y eso ni siquiera es todo.
El cese de la producción petrolera en 10
o 15 años podría traer consigo también
otro gran problema: la puesta en duda de la
seguridad del suministro energético.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque el sistema eléctrico colombiano
es muy dependiente de la generación hidroeléctrica.
Para que os hagáis una idea, durante los
periodos de normalidad hidrológica, la generación
hidroeléctrica puede llegar a abastecer más
de tres cuartas partes de toda la demanda.
Sin embargo, cuando se producen fenómenos
como el niño y los consiguientes periodo
de sequía, entonces el país tiene un problema.
Hasta ahora los hidrocarburos han solventado
la papeleta, pero si estos se terminan, todo
podría complicarse y mucho.
Sea como sea, ya lo veis, Colombia parece
dispuesta a sacrificar decenas de miles de
millones de dólares y miles de empleos para
luchar contra el calentamiento global.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Ahora la pregunta es para todos vosotros:
¿Qué os parece el plan de Colombia?
¿Estáis de acuerdo con él?
Dejadnos vuestras impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y como siempre, si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
a VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.